so where i'm going to begin is i'm going
to start with this force equation
and we've written it down so it can be
kind of our starting point and the first
thing i notice
is that there's a common factor on both
sides which is mass
mass is you know just a constant that i
can divide through presumably
the boat is not like shedding people out
the side
as they go through so i'm going to treat
mass as constant so i'm just going to
divide through and that gives me
x double dot there's my acceleration
equals
what do i get here well i've got this
minus v plus
10v squared on the numerator and then
i've got
100 on the denominator okay so far
so good now what do i do with this well
i'm trying to get towards
v as a function of x and i've got
acceleration
over here and then i've got all of this
in terms of v it's a function of
v right so what am i going to do here i
need to get
acceleration in a different form and
i've got many different forms if you
recall
that makes it easier for me to work with
and i'm going to
pause remember and see if you can post
in the chat for me which form is going
to be most
useful in order to say if this is
acceleration and i've got all of this
stuff
minus v plus 10 v squared et cetera on a
hundred if i've got all of that over on
the
uh right hand side which form of
acceleration
and you may need the reference sheet or
if you want to go back through your
notes
which one's going to be most useful to
me so i'll give you a moment to have a
think
and by the way i should point out um you
know all the forms of acceleration
are equal to each other so it's not as
though um
you know one answer can't be used but
there will be answers that allow us to
be lazier
and more efficient with our methods so i
see a few answers coming in that's
excellent
okay now um angered
and joon have suggested that we write in
v dv on dx now
if you go back to when we were doing
simple harmonic motion we also had up
our sleeves and i'll just write it over
here
d on dx of half v square now these are
both
decent candidates right i'm really glad
that they're
sort of glad no one posted in the chat
like oh maybe like d squared x on dt
squared right that would be a bad
candidate
not wrong but not helpful because
there's nothing in terms of time
over here in fact there is no situation
or no information provided to us
about time both of these are reasonable
candidates because they're both
somewhat in terms of v right but i'm
going to say that this suggestion from
anger and june
will be more helpful because if you have
a look at what i have on my right hand
side
you can see that there is not just a
common factor of m that i've already
divided through by but there's a common
factor of
v which i can divide through by so this
over here on the left hand side
this is acceleration as a function of
velocity so i'm going to go ahead and
use that
and now i can divide through by v so
what does that give us
i'm going to get dv on dx on the left
hand side
and then i'll leave that minus sign out
the front 1 plus 10
v inside the brackets and that's still
divided by
100 okay now where can i go
well remember what the question says we
want to find v
as a function of x so i've got sort of
all the pieces right i've got
um v's i've got x's and v's over here
except i've got everything in terms of
derivatives right dv
and dx separately so clearly i'm going
to need to integrate at some point to
get the x actually appearing not just
a dx in order to do that i think
probably the easiest way to go about
this is to try and separate out my
variables
a little bit you can see i've got my dv
over here but all the v's that should go
with it are on the other side
so i'm going to do this kind of together
get the dvs
all over on the left left on your point
of view
left right and then all of the x's on
the right so let's have a go at that
i'm going to go and divide through by
this this numerator up here
so i'm going to get 1 on 1
plus 10 v dv
so that's what i get from the left hand
side and the reason why i haven't
written the dx is because i'm about to
multiply through
by dx get all my dvs on one side dx is
on the other side so would that leave me
with
equal to minus 1 i didn't divide through
by that negative
over 100 and then that gives me dx on
the right hand side
okay so this is promising this is a lot
of mental
progress cognitive progress since we
started i can get one better than this
though because
i know i have to integrate eventually
but i think i can make this easier for
myself
have a look at what you've got over here
right you've got this
oneplus 10v on the denominator i want
you to post in the chat
what category of function am i going to
end up with
when i integrate this you know all the
different families of functions
you know polynomials we've got
trigonometry etc
inverse trig when i integrate the left
hand side what kind of function
am i going to end up with can you go
ahead and post that for me what do you
reckon
thank you sasmit yay fantastic are you
jordan charm getting in real quick
um and even laser in their notation this
is going to be a log right
i can do something better to make this
or rather something easier to make this
as
obvious as a log i want to have this f
dash on
f and that's not f dash at the moment
the
f being 1 plus 10 v i want a 10 at the
top
so i'm going to go ahead and multiply
both sides by 10 and that will give me
this 10 on
1 plus 10 v dv equals
multiply through by 10 on the right hand
side that gives me 1 over 10
or negative 1 over 10 i should say and
i'm ready to go
i'm going to integrate in fact i'm so
lazy then i'm going to take everything
that's here
just so you can see what i've done and
now i'm just going to maybe i'll do it
in another color just to make it really
obvious what i'm doing here
i'm just going to slap my integrals onto
both sides and i already have the
variables of integration
on each side in one case it's dv in one
case it's dx because i separated
everything out
okay what am i going to get as you guys
mentioned i've got that log there
1 plus 10 v is the f on the inside log
of that
i'm going to get a constant integration
but i'm going to get a constant
integration on the right hand side also
so i might as well just lump them into
one constant
i'm going to get minus x over 10
plus that constant some of you're going
to say mr we why aren't there absolute
value signs here
i could put absolute value signs but
it's worth noting that in the vast
majority of the mechanics questions
we're going to be interested in
really only the positive values are the
ones that we need to worry about
there's no problem with you putting
absolute value signs there but as you
can see
um and because i'm sort of thinking
ahead for where my question is going to
go
it isn't going to be necessary for us to
put in negative values of v think about
what that would mean
by the way in order to get some negative
in
here that would require the absolute
value signs you're going to have to have
the boat
traveling back towards the start line
right the starting point so that's why
i sort of am thinking and realizing i
don't need to worry about those
okay now i've made a lot of progress
right i've successfully integrated i've
got x in there
and i wanted if you go back to the
question v as a function
of x so i want to get v equals something
something something
and i'm getting pretty close there i
should try and sort out this constant of
integration right so i want you to have
a think
and maybe i i'll just sort of um make
sure that you've got this written down
here because that's pretty important
if you haven't already caught up with me
i need to go back to the original
question
so that you can see with me how we're
going to evaluate this constant of
integration
what information can we use go ahead
post it in the chat why you or what you
could use you think in this question
i'll leave all that information there
we've used a lot of the information but
there's some we haven't used yet
yes thank you again quick off the mark
or also notice the absolute value signs
as well
i'm going to use the condition and i
might as well highlight it let's use a
different color
like this here we go right here
that is thinner than i thought it would
be that's a bit better okay there we go
so the boat crosses the finish line with
speed
5.5 meters per second so crossing the
finish line as you recall from our
definition of
x is x equals 0. so
x equals 0 is crossing the finish line
and then there's this
velocity here it's in the forward
direction so that's why it's going to be
positive
5.5 so what i can do is i can say
in some ways this is like the initial
conditions um
initial is not quite the right word
because that's a time word but i can say
from the question
and it is important to put this uh line
of working in here right
x equals 0 implies that the velocity
is 5.5 so i can just do a straight
substitution
into this equation up here let's call
that
one so i'm going to call that or
substitute into
substitute those values into one
what do we get here well on the left
hand side i've got 1
plus 10 v v is 5.5 so i'm getting 55
out of 10 v and i'm putting in x
equals 0 so i just get 0 plus c
so here's my constant it's log of 56
whatever that
happens to be so i can take that back
to equation 1 and say therefore
log of 1 plus 10 v there's the left-hand
side unchanged
equals negative x on 10 plus
log of 56 okay so this point we just
need to do a little bit of tidying up
what i want to do is find v
as a function of x so i'm just going to
have to rearrange this
use some of my knowledge of logs and
exponentials and how they fit together
so you can see i've got the natural log
so that's base e in fact i'm going to do
this on the next page because i'm around
the space
i think i can be cheeky and stick it in
there you're going to get e to the power
of
everything that you had up here
that's all going to be i might make it a
bit smaller since it's the index there
there you go i've also got index laws
that i can use here so when you've got
this common base and it's got
you know this is like e to the power of
a plus b that's the same as e to the a
times e to the b and the reason why
that's useful
is if i write this as e to the power of
here's the a
and here is the b hopefully you
recognize it's sort of like one of the
early results that you learned in
logarithms that e to the power of log
something is just that something e to
the log k
is k so in this case this whole term
here is just going to become
56 which will dramatically simplify
things for me
while i'm at it remembering that i'm
trying to make v the subject i'm going
to subtract
1 from both sides and then here on my
next line
i reckon we can be pretty tiny and do a
few things at the same time
i'm going to divide through everything
on the right hand side by 10
that leaves me with 56 e to the negative
x on 10 minus 1.
ta-da there's v as a function of
x so let's just pause this is part 8 by
the way we're done
let's just pause before we go on have a
look at this
let me just highlight it here this
result that we've gotten here v as a
function of
x what kind of model is this right what
does the calculus led us to this
e to the power of let me just zoom in
there right e to the power of
negative x on 10 and then all the rest
of this stuff is just kind of like
scaling in position right
this thing here this is the core this
part here is the engine that sort of
tells us what's going on and what
behavior we ought to be able to expect
from this boat what does e to the
negative x
on 10 roughly look like we know what an
exponential curve
looks like ordinarily e to the x is just
going to start flow and then off it goes
e to the negative x on 10 doesn't start
low and then go high it's been
horizontally reflected right so think
back to all the graphing stuff we did
all the way back in advanced right
therefore it's going to start high and
then come down low this is an
exponential decay model
much like say the half-life of a
radioactive material
and that makes sense because if you
think back to our equations of drag or
our expressions to drag here right
the faster you're going the more drag
you experience
and that's why you can see if v is
larger than this whole expression
one over 100 mv which is the form drag
that's going to be
larger more velocity more drag right and
it's the same thing over here but even
more so you've got a v squared term
there
with the skin drag so greater velocity
means
um greater slowing down a greater force
acting against you resisting you
and so it sort of makes sense that the
further you go the slower you go
and the slower you go the less you're
slowing down over time right
that's what you expect from an
exponential decay model
so even though you don't need to know
that to answer part a i think it's
really important you're always
interpreting the results that you get